well hi I'm Rick Baker and I am
I'm so proud and honored to be the
presenter of this award to my idol
my my mentor and my friend for over
forty three years the greatest makeup
artist alive is finally referred to as
The Godfather of makeup not just because
he did Brando's makeup for that film but
because he took makeup to a whole new
level he it's unbelievable what this man
has done
I mean his work inspired a whole
generation of up-and-coming makeup
artists myself included many of them
here at this table he he taught us he
like he said he didn't have trade
secrets he would go out of his way he
was unbelievable about the way he shared
information he would record his thought
process what made him come with it up
with his technique what materials he
used why use the materials where he
bought the materials what he would do
differently if he was to do that makeup
again he would record all this and he
would actually he he typed it up and
bought himself a mimeograph machine if
you remember those things he and he
actually would make me a graph of these
these notes and give them to any
aspiring makeup artists artists or
anybody I mean if it was not uncommon to
see dick on some street corner in
Manhattan handing people about said this
is this is how I did the bullet hits in
The Godfather and this is how I made
Linda Blair's throat swell up on the
Exorcist you know it you know another
reason he's known as the godfather of
our makeup is because he makes you
offers that you can't refuse
he made me one of those when he called
me up and asked me to live in his house
and work in his basement as his lab
assistant on the Exorcist I mean I could
not pass that up
and I was afraid I was gonna find a dead
horse head in my bed so I I said yes it
is now the greatest pleasure that I
would like to present this honorary
Oscar
- the greatest makeup artist who ever
live mr. dick Smith
well I'll read this and then I'll say
something that I don't have to read
ladies and gentlemen please forgive me
my memory is not very good these days
when I watched the wonderful film they
just showed I kept thinking gosh that
fellow had a great career but I do
remember with great fondness everyone at
this table and how much they have meant
to me in my life I will never forget
tonight from the bottom of my heart
thank you all this has been an
incredible joy one of the greatest I've
ever had in my whole life I have loved
being a makeup artist so much but this
kind of puts the crown of cat on all of
that all of that to have so much
kindness given to me oh and one huge
piece it's just too much
you